في اقل من 48 ساعه تعلن ايران عن مقتل
ثاني ضباطها بقصف تقول انه اسرائيلي
استهدف محيط العاصمه السوريه دمشق مقداد
مقداني قتل متاثرا بجراحه التي اصيب بها
بقصف فجر الجمعه الفائت ليكون ثاني قتيلا
من ضباط الحرس الثوري في القصف نفسه بعد
مقتل ميلاد حيدري الذي اعترف طهران بمقتله
في وقت سابق خلال الشهر الاخير كثفت
اسرائيل من عملياتها الجويه في سوريا
امتدت الاستهدافات خلالها من جنوب البلاد
الى اقصى شمالها هجوم الاحد في حمص استهدف
قاعده تيفور الجويه قرب تدمر ومطار الضبعه
القريب من القصير الهجوم الجديد يعتبر
الثالثه خلال اسبوع بعد قصف مشابه على
ليلتين متتاليتين في الثلاث ين والحادي
والثلاثين من مارس كذلك فان مقتل الضابطين
الايرانيين قرب دمشق جاء في قصف يعتبر
السادس من نوعه خلال اذار المنصرم سبقته
هجمات على حلب وحماه
الخارجيه الايرانيه وعلى لسان المتحدث
باسمها ناصر كناني توعد برد مناسب في
المكان والوقت المناسبين كلام كررته طهران
كثيرا بينما تقول اسرائيل ان من يستهدف
امنها سيدفع ثمنا باهظا